hi everyone i'm kevin durant here's a
first look at our new show swagger
no way i'm not gonna make it right coach
back
[Applause]
the genesis of this project was simply
me wanting to depict what went on as a
kid in a youth basketball circuit
swagger is kind of a cross between
friday night lights and youth basketball
that was introduced to me by kevin
durant when i sat with kd i realized i
could create a show that actually had a
lot more to do than basketball it really
became a show about life it's not just
talented people who make it it's
talented people who make the right
decisions swagger is a lessening growing
up the million kids around the country
use basketball as a coping mechanism it
was almost like therapy for us as kids a
place for us to get away from what was
going on at home
[Music]
my son will take your team from good to
oh my god
there will never be a shot in the entire
series where somebody will shoot the
ball and it will cut to the basketball
going through the hoop
reggie was like no you're going to make
these baskets
[Laughter]
the authenticity is something that we
talked about early on that was one of
the first conversations we had is that
we want real basketball players we don't
want to just train actors to play
basketball we want to train basketball
players because that'll give us the most
authentic feel for the show just being
able to play this same sport i love all
over tv just to be known for my craft
just really happy for me let's go scrub
get loud
it's fresh we never seen the competitive
hardcore nature of basketball at 13 14
years old whenever you mess up you have
the spotlight on you but you have the
world watching at such a young age and
the world can be cruel you're not just
building ball players
you're building young men whether it's
high school college or the nba it's a
machine behind us so a lot comes with
that let's keep winning
swagger on the surface means bravado and
confidence but in the context of our
show it really means having a car is
bigger than yourself you can't fake
swagger it's like an energy inside of
you to me swagger means just to be the
best that you can be every single day no
matter what obstacles are in front of
you
so help me god if you don't take those
thoughts off my son i'll have your badge
while we were shooting the world changed
some of the wrong officers you're here
for that protest black people happen to
deal with police brutality and just the
injustice of that it's sad to think
about how many people are going to be
connected to the hard times that we show
in swagger but when you
watch anything that you feel connection
with that's when that piece of art has
the ability to inspire
ultimately it's not a show about
basketball it's a show about growing up
in america and basketball is a backdrop
we are on this journey to
find ourselves to find the cause bigger
than ourselves and so in many ways
that's the sort of spiritual you know
north star if you will for swagger
you walk on that court with swagger you
walk off with swagger
[Music]
you